pendant l'allocution d'Emmanuel Macron
un objet visible à l'écran a attiré mon
attention je me suis demandé ce que
c'était assez vite j'ai trouvé que
c'était une pendule d'officier une sorte
de petite horloge portative là et les
deux dos est-ce qu'on voit c'est le
mécanisme pour la remonter des pendule
les Lisée en compte une synthèse et on
envoie souvent à côté du président pour
son portrait officiel des 2017 il avait
par exemple posé devant celle-ci une
pendule qui a la particularité d'avoir
deux cadrans un de chaque côté plusieurs
photos la montre à son bureau et il est
aussi déplacé lors de conseils des
ministres pour permettre au ministre
présent des deux côtés de la table de
voir là
bon là vous l'aurez remarqué c'est pas
de cette horloge qui s'agit ici en fait
c'est une pendule plus petite à un seul
cadran c'est un modèle que l'on retrouve
sur des photos d'anciens présidents
comme François Mitterrand Jacques Chirac
ou François Hollande selon l'Élysée
Emmanuel Macron l'utilisera lui lors de
réunion et en Conseil des ministres
[Musique]